you know now we have the opportunity to
host a second round game at home
you know hopefully it's uh below 30.
but i think we're going to be a
tough team to deal with in the playoffs
aaron rodgers talking about his green
bay packers who have emerged as the
number two seed in the nfc who would
have expected that but they are there at
number two if you're watching on nbcsn
you see that glorious bracket it begins
this weekend both nfc wild card games on
sunday it's the sixth seeded vikings at
the three-seeded saints at 105 eastern
on fox 4 40 p.m eastern on nbc the fifth
seeded seahawks take on the fourth
seeded eagles congratulations to them
for winning four in a row to capture the
nfc east and then the lowest remaining
seed the following saturday is at santa
clara to take on the 49ers the highest
remaining seed will be at lambeau field
on sunday to take on the packers and
i
any of those six teams could emerge yes
any of them there isn't one team i look
at there although i have no faith in
kirk cousins ability to win on the road
a big game but you know what they could
get through the first two rounds without
playing at night yeah which which
there's there's some benefit there as it
relates to kirk cousins right dalvin
cook is healthy sure the vikings are
in position to make any game they play
interesting and every team i think even
the eagles
the dog masks get them back out we've
seen it time and again they are the
lesser team on the field but they find a
way to win well they're tough they're
battle tested there's no doubt about
that but i think like to your big
picture point
i still look at it and think it's the
49er saints
okay or the cream of the crop here now
i'm with you i understand with dalvin
cook healthy the vikings they're gonna
be a pain in the butt the eagles they're
battle tested but i think ultimately
against the elite cream of the crop
teams there's just not enough offense
there to go around uh so i don't have
much faith there seattle okay i always
give them a fighting chance but i still
think the 49ers and the saints are the
two best teams now the interesting thing
as of yesterday is the fact that green
bay got that first round bye and i you
know i know you've heard me say this to
me the first round bye
uh was no bigger to any team in all of
football than the green bay packers
they're a different team at home than
they are compared away there is
something to go and up to lambeau it's
not an easy place to play especially
this time of the year aaron rodgers and
green bay have it mastered as far as
that is concerned they feed off the
emotion of the crowd there i don't think
green bay was good enough to win three
games in a row one on one at home and
then two on the road but now with only
having to play you know maybe one game
on the road i do i give them a legit
chance to make the super bowl we're
going into yesterday i wasn't sure i
really felt that way until i saw them
get that that first round bye and they
almost blew it because that was the
worst first half of football i've ever
seen aaron rodgers play in a football
game uh and they almost lost to an
inferior detroit lions team and if they
play like that in a playoff game they're
done they're done they they are not
going to have the luxury of waking up in
the second half against one of these
teams
and the detroit lions exactly right
you're right i mean
they were fortunate that they played a
team that's you know not not exactly
healthy or hitting on all cylinders
lions came out hot but you know it's if
you're watching this on tv right now it
was one missed throw after another with
aaron rodgers in the first half the
start of the third quarter all of that
but just like any great player we see
like steph curry or whoever it may be
once he started to hit a few throws all
of a sudden we started to go oh wow okay
here he goes and you know he just got
hot and enough time there to give them a
chance to win the football game and
that's what they did and and you know
that's what makes
the quote we played from aaron rodgers
where we're going to be a dangerous team
in the playoffs
it's hard to reconcile that belief with
what we saw yesterday yesterday was not
impressive it was impressive that they
found a way to pull it together and
avoid what would have been a disaster
losing to the david blau lions with a
buy on the line would have been
as bad or worse than what happened to
the patriots yesterday when they blew
their buy at home against the dolphins
and and and you did to be puffing your
chest out a little bit after that i i
don't know i don't know that last night
was a good scotch night or a bad scotch
night for aaron rodgers because it
looked like for a long time it was going
to be a bad scotch night i think it's
kind of a mediocre lukewarm scotch night
because they got some stuff they got to
fix and they got two weeks to do it yeah
if they're going to be in the nfc
championship would definitely do i mean
one of the big things
the packers have to play you know
defense and then
play through the run game on the
offensive side of the ball the packers
have been great at holding teams to
field goals they're one of the better
defenses in football as far as points
allowed you know when they do get in the
red zone they score touchdowns they're
almost like that old new england
patriots like you kick a field goal we
score a touchdown you could feel oh we
scored a touchdown you could feel we
scored a touchdown it's 21-9 even the
goal the game's been very even that's
what they do but uh yes scary because
the detroit ran the ball on them
yesterday made some plays in the pass
game we thought the packers had sured up
that run defense and
they got to be a little more consistent
with aaron jones i think that's the
biggest thing they're not explosive
enough at receiver and rogers isn't on
fire enough for me just to say drop back
in shotgun and throw it every play aaron
rodgers looked like he had a serious
injury remember that in the first half
we were watching it we saw the way he
hit the ground it looked bad yeah he
ended up being okay 25 carries for 100
yards they need him to be able to get it
done when aaron jones aaron jones aaron
rodriguez
there's too many errands on that team
change your name we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports